[Música]
ah
e
[Música]
i
realmente lo que creo que nos faltaba
era vida a pesar de toda la situación
hay gente que se queja que dice que la
gente no puede ser feliz en medio de lo
que estamos y creo que está bien
respirar más allá de lo malo uno tiene
que seguir viviendo y creo que eso es lo
que estamos logrando
[Música]
muchas personas por inseguridad no
regresaban al centro ahora creo que de
hace unos años para acá se ha estado
trabajando y mejorando eso ahorita hay
menos boleros en la calle y se puede
garantizar un poco la seguridad
[Música]
porque si hago un sitio público nuevo
y eso es lo que justamente ocurre en
cualquier espacio público cuando todos
vamos
[Música]